m m's
have gone trans
they're trans they're not they're not
transitioning from one sex to another
sex
they're not transitioning necessarily
from dark chocolate to milk chocolate
say
certainly not white chocolate could you
imagine how racist that would be but the
m m's
are going woke
mars incorporated the candy company that
owns
m ms
gave an announcement yesterday they said
we took a deep look at our characters
both inside and out and have evolved
their look personalities and backstories
to be more representative of today's
society as the world changes so do we
the characters are now going to have
quote a fresh modern take on their style
and more nuanced personalities to
underscore the importance of
self-expression and power of community
through storytelling because today's
quote more dynamic progressive world
demands it
we are talking about
candy-coated chocolate bites and we are
getting a dissertation on the
progressive nature of our society
why are they doing this i actually think
there's something deeper going on in
this story than just the silliness of a
piece of candy going trans
mars says quote studies show our desire
to belong is as strong as our desire to
be loved and that desire is common for
all people irrespective of culture race
ethnicity geography or location again
this release coming from a candy bar
company they showed
the the mars company showed a glimpse of
this new program in an instagram video
they say we're on a mission to create a
world where everyone feels they belong
using the power of fun join us for all
fun kind head on over
so they're saying this world is
progressive so inevitably the world is
going to move more in the leftist
direction it's the same sort of thing
that joe biden and kamala harris and the
rest of the democrats are assuming when
they say that elections that they lose
will be illegitimate they're saying the
world is inevitably going to become more
progressive and it's good that it's
going to become more progressive and so
anytime that that progress with a
capital p is impeded by definition
something has gone wrong by definition
that election is illegitimate but what
what m m's are pursuing right now what
our society is pursuing right now is two
contradictory objectives
they say that they want more
self-expression
they also say that they want more
commonality community and sense of
belonging you can't have both you can't
have both those are
at odds with one another and our culture
is radically pursuing both and it's why
we're tearing apart at the seams
eminem's
much like our cultural leaders our candy
and our cultural leaders want us to
pursue radical self
expression
meaning if you're a man and you think
you're a woman then you better dress up
in dresses you better wear high heels
you better rub some lipstick all over
your face frankly you should probably
mutilate your body you should go under
the knife you should pump yourself full
of hormones because that's your true
self-expression
now
i don't think that really is your
self-expression i think that yourself is
more than just your delusions i think
your body has something to do with
yourself i think reality has something
to say about yourself but
but but in the views of of our modern
world
the cultural leaders say whatever whim
or fancy you've got you need to express
that but also gosh we're all so lonely
we're also we're all so isolated we
don't even seem to be able to speak to
one another anymore we don't we don't
seem to speak a common language and so
what we really want also is community we
all want to be included we want to be
together
but if everybody is off
speaking their own language not talking
to one another not regarding the demands
or views of their neighbors if everyone
is off forming their own to quote
anthony kennedy in one of the dumbest
supreme court decisions ever planned
parenthood v casey which has a lot to do
with what we're talking about right now
because we're here in dc at the march
for live
if everyone's doing that
forming our own concept of existence
we can't have community
we've got
to find a middle ground here
we've got we've got to
pick frankly because we've gone so far
in one direction that we don't have
anything left in the other we've gone so
far down the radical self-expression
rabbit hole that we we don't have any
community left anymore and so the answer
to this
is to limit self-expression the answer
to this is to place some limits upon
this mistaken view of liberty we have
which is nothing but licentiousness and
delusion it's a problem not just for the
left the left is pushing it obviously
it's a problem for the right too i'm so
glad that you liked that clip i liked it
as well if you want to get more of those
videos
ring the bell subscribe get the
notifications head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
type in the michael knowles show boom
subscribe leave a five star review if
you wouldn't mind we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]
you